yo what up people Ryan right over here
and Katie Dubois right here yep so we're
gonna watch the trailer for a highly
requested trailer from fans of the real
rejects for a movie called pixels pixel
stars Peter Dinklage and one of the
greatest comedians makes every comedy he
does wonderfully praised by critics
super heart he's just an amazing
comedian Adam Sandler all his movies
were solid okay no everyone knows the
truth about Adam Sandler movies but I
still find them kind of funny
his work has gotten I mean the stuff
he's done recently in the past like five
years has been good yeah I don't know if
this is a comedy or drama but when he's
in dramas he's really good yeah he's
kind of funny so it's like a perfect
combination for him like I thought funny
people was very underrated I don't know
what this is but everyone keeps keep
saying so check that no
I need that
very much aware of all these things just
reach
some alien life force
you like video games
to attack us it's like minecraft how
interesting
yeah that's cool
donkey
just a barrel of engine
we always take them happiness with
ghosts
I'm kidding we are all gonna die I'm
just
may I introduce to you professor Liu
tonic the creator of pac-man
come on is one back you see professor
Vitaly what are you doing I will talk to
him
he's my son oh my sweet little boy look
how big you've grown I know
good boy
yeah nice that is interesting that is
definitely interesting I like that last
moment I've liked him having a father
son yeah kind of reminds me of like one
of those intense comedies I think of
like matter I don't know why this movie
comes to mind like evolution you
remember that with David Duchovny well I
was like one of those sci-fi comedies
that was kind of intense at times that's
cool videogames come into life they're
in pixel version and they're attacking
this city that's so that's funny the way
it's executed it looks like it's
captured really well yeah I like Kevin
James Adam Sandler and together they're
really funny it would be fun to watch in
three days it looks like it'd be a blast
to watch like this could be a comedy
that if it's done right like you say
with any movie but if this comedy works
this looks like a family comedy and if
it works
this could get Adam Sandler some respect
again he's lost a lot of respect because
he consistently makes movies that a lot
of people don't like so this looks like
different though it doesn't look like
some stupid movie where Adam Sandler's
like oh I want to make some money but
kick it on an island for a while this
looks like a lot of work really went
into it the effects look good the
cinematography looks good it looks like
it's gonna be fun upbeat energetic and
funny yeah it's like a great summer film
it's amazing family movies are so in
right now in the last couple years just
bugging out those awesome family movies
I know
fam it's like they realize that there's
a more people involved in a family when
it comes to the demographic you know
yeah it's like husband wife kids yeah
that's like 4p it's not just like Disney
for like toddlers and then like yeah
dramatic films for adults like there's a
whole range
it's like SH not a spy's a lot like
smart marketing yeah Wow we can work for
Studios what what what why I keep
looking at the camera then you what are
we doing he put up the opera silence
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects Katie
Dubois has a channel too gonna be
starting up graphic novel reviews so
subscribe now wait for those and check
got her fun videos in the meantime you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter shoutouts will continue but
there's so many requests now that
they're gonna have to be on separate
videos that shout-out videos so if you
want a shout-out go to facebook.com
slash the real reject shoutouts earn
yourself a shout-out by saying something
interesting like Kati would look good
with a third boob or Ryan would look
good if he shaved his head which that
are we talking about Oh buzz zing woo go
that's funny yeah
comedy comedies funny comedy comedy it's
funny that's what we have comedy 20
times funny times